the best way to start with somebody is
when you take two blocks of triangular
pieces of wood they're called wedges
and you smash them together
at sort of like when you're supposed to
hear a gunshot all they're usually going
to say is gunshot and you go you know
you're supposed to hear something and
they go smash he's like
[Music]
i was 18 when i made halloween i played
the girl next door the one who went to
school the one who fought back i think
classics are classic speak i think
halloween could be one
it's sort of like a poor man's version
of a classic
because it was done without any blood it
was done with that there's no blood in
halloween people think that these movies
are all slash and no slice and dice
movies there's no slicing and dicing in
halloween you think you see a lot more
than you do
what's the boogie man i mean a lot of
guys like to
i take like them i never have
it was only an irony that i was in them
so in the sense of i don't understand
why people like them i don't know why i
guess they like to be scared what an
excellent day for an exorcism i saw the
exorcist and it was the only horror film
i will ever see ever forget it i don't
see them i'm a good date for a horror
film i end up in their lap the whole
time i think i'll go to vancouver now
slash trash scream queen
i think it's great people used to want
people to like them as an actress your
your joy is when an audience identifies
with you and your characters and goes
out to see you now if horror films have
given me what people have called or
described as a cult status
all that tells me is that there's a
group of people
who've liked the films i've made and
have maybe liked me
and if they liked me then
they're gonna like me again i mean
that's all we're supposed to do is try
to get an audience to like you so if
they've done that then i mean i think
that's great
[Music]
you